qui nous met dans la peau des sportifs
d'élite ici au canada
nous allons glisser sur les pentes de
ski enneigées parfois périlleuses de
tout le pays
et bien sûr on va parler de l'hiver au
canada on va pas tout faire ce qu'on
vient d'écrire non nous en fait pas
parce qu'on n'a pas le temps et surtout
pas les expertises le talent je vais
commencer par le talent évidemment c'est
à la base de toute chose ici autour de
la table lorsqu'il est question de
talent il faut plutôt se tourner vers
notre collègue anne marie bonjour aux
fans
bonjour stéphane stéphane parent c'est
le parent c'est le nom de famille pour
se présenter
oui bien sûr stéphane parent oui et léo
gimeno c'est notre webmestre de la
section espagnole aujourd'hui qui est
avec nous encore une fois bon journée au
bonjour bonjour tout le monde
alors quand on parle de tout le monde là
c'est ce qui nous écoutent bien qu'ils
nous regardent d'abord sur facebook la
et vendredi alors même qu'on est en
train de commettre grand péché aux états
unis
à 11 heures du matin pourquoi que j'ai
donné mon opinion pas du tout je parle
d'elle à la religion quelque part bon
maintenant c'est aussi des gens qui nous
regardent sur la vidéo sur youtube
à compter de dimanche sur tintin le
canada et bien sûr ceux qui nous
écoutent en deux dimensions seulement
niveau de l'émission sonore de tam-tam
canada nous offrons toujours le service
mais on ne sait pas encore pour combien
de temps là je fais une blague bien sûr
ne vous en faites pas on n'est pas comme
je sais pas moi paul ou des grosses
compagnies qui retire le service après
du mois seulement parce qu'ils ont une
nouvelle technologie à offrir non radio
canada international est un diffuseur
public table et publie maintenant choses
sérieuses
je voudrais parler avant d'aller de
glisser vers notre sujet préféré de
l'hiver et des sports d'hiver au canada
je voulais absolument vous apporter à
tous aussi autour d' atteinte de cette
lettre qui nous a fait réfléchir ici à
la station cette semaine c'est signé par
jean tu sais pas d'où il vient quelle
est son nom de famille
j'espère que c'est pas par an pour les
intimes voici ce qu'il dit on va
demander à anne-marie nous livra mais
oui évidemment surtout que je me sens
concerné à travers la lettre alors je
vais vous
yanis est scellé sa porte notre émission
la semaine dernière qui portait elle sur
les dangers de rouler trop rapidement
surtout lives and we la conduite
automobile surtout l'hiver mais bon la
conduite rapide en général comme vous
allez le voir dans la lettre alors j'en
écris alors que l'on ne cesse de faire
de la prévention quant aux limites de
vitesse vous n'avez rien trouvé de mieux
que de vous vanter d'avoir fait des
excès de vitesse
que ce soit en toute légalité se vante
la journaliste ou dans l'illégalité pour
les autres c'est inacceptable de votre
part quel exemple vous donner quelle
inconscience
pour information à la journaliste qui se
vantait d'avoir roulé à 200 km/heure en
allemagne l'allemagne garde jalousement
ses données d'accidents notamment celles
portant sur les morts à cause de la
vitesse excessive quand on cache quelque
chose trois petits points j'espère
monsieur parent que vous rectifier le
tir la prochaine fois en expliquant à
nos jeunes que ce n'est pas un exemple à
suivre
la vitesse du point point à la ligne pas
tout à fait il ya eu une réponse à ce
commentaire qui vient pas de nous mais
qui vient d'un autre éditeur et suit
l'insigne son nom de famille dansereau
critiqué christian de son prénom il
habite au canada et voici on va demander
à léo unis mais les réponses de cet
auditeur agents hockey est franchement
franchement un jeune je sais pas si tu
as regardé la même excellente émission
des tam-tams que nous autres les
animateurs se sont fait un point
d'honneur à préciser à chaque détour de
leur conservation de leur conversation
avec une conservation oui et que la
vitesse tue et encore plus en hiver et
ils ont eu l'intelligence de partager
avec nous leurs propres erreurs du passé
concernant leur foi où ils ont eu la
méga rdda des cellules être vite
oui oui absolument c'est vrai que mon
quand on est jeune on est fous en
général
on peut aimer la vitesse bon c'est sûr
mais c'est sûr c'est pas un bon exemple
à suivre si un plus dans les cadets la
montre que j'ai dit que je roulais ben
c'est pas moi qui conduis là montaugé
théâtre il ya quelqu'un qui m'a amené à
ces vitesses là j'ai pas aimé
ouais c'est pas c'est pas le mec sa
place ufc mais janvier sur les accidents
en allemagne il ya beaucoup d'accidents
est ce qu'il y en a plus qu ailleurs pas
certaines par contre quand il ya un
accident ce sont de sacrés gros
carambolage et beaucoup de morts
beaucoup de voitures impliquées c'est
normal quand on arrive à cette ville
j'ai vu un documentaire a déjà
américaine ya trois ou quatre ans de
cela je pourrais pas aux tirs
la source précisément mais c'étaient des
ambulanciers en allemagne qui parlait
qui témoigne un des deux ce qu'ils
ramassaient aux côtés de l'autoroute
après un de ces accidents à très très
haute vitesse et infirmiers des kids est
si les gens pouvaient voir ce que l'on
voit il remettrait tout de suite en
question cette politique du
laisser-faire sur les autoroutes à
pleine vitesse 1 alors je pense que
notre détergents au fin fond des choses
vous avez raison vous mettez le doigt
sur quelque chose
rouler à 120 kilomètres/heure c'est
extrêmement rare que je le fais des fois
c'est parce qu'il faut dépasser un fou
là qui roule à 110 maîtresse pas que le
sport aux jeux 520 kg par 86 des gens
j'ai déjà vu des gens sur l'autoroute
rouler à la limite minimale qui et quoi
de 60 km sont un danger public
véritable temps ci je sais c'est
problématique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
je sais pas si et si un des données sur
les accidents mais a beaucoup déjà âgées
qui conduisent à moins de 60 dans les
autoroutes au québec mais bien ça c'est
très dangereux
c'est pape le danger c'est très
dangereux et non roulait trop vite c'est
dangereux ne pas rouler assez vite c'est
dangereux alors roulé comme tous les
autres se seraient six mois c'est
certainement bien s'ils ont partagé la
route
je ne vois pas ça tous les jours je
passe trois heures et demie en auto je
vois c'est sur wii revient encore un bon
je dirai pas ce qui s'est passé réussi à
des gens qui veulent vraiment aller je
ne sais pas où à noël avant
à 20 roupies bas et c'est très loin et
noël c'est encore en presque douze mois
alors on va tirer notre et là dessus oui
on va prendre l'autoroute pour aller
vers les sports d'hiver et on fait ça
lentement parce qu'on appelle que la
vitesse se tue dans questions de sport
d'hiver c'était la question tu aimes pas
mais c'est toujours la question tam-tam
écoute cette semaine ses radis bay notre
webmestre du côté francophone qui était
à la caméra je pense que c'était
mercredi on s'est dit mon dieu on a
oublié de filmer notre question de la
mettre sur youtube elle m'a dit on y va
tout de suite on planche et on va
regarder ce que ça donne font évidemment
augmenter un peu le son pour même pour
les sequins tamby sports d'hiver alors
on est très très contents d'avoir su
beaucoup de réponse cette semaine par
rapport à cette question plus à chaque
semaine sa boîte
le commentaire de brice dja ou au
cameroun il dit j'aime bien le bobsleigh
nous aussi nous mêmes mots j'en ai
jamais fait c'est un peu dangereux ça va
vite ça va très vite
un auditeur qui est au cameroun au
jovani bengono nkama qui nous écoute on
le soupçonne parce qu'il le fait toutes
les semaines sur facebook live
alors bonjour geovanni voici ce qui est
à nous dire alors il dit bon ici au
cameroun il ne neige pas mais j'aime le
ski de fond je suis fan d'alex harvey
skieur de fond canadien ça c'est moi
qu'ils ajoutent la et j'aimerais y faire
ce sport au moins une fois juste pour
voir comment c'est bien petit
commentaire à pdci c'est arrivé il ya
quelques minutes à peine
gs que j'ai perdu ma feuille
probablement mais je n'ai j'ai ma
mémoire ne fait n'est pas occulté
affaiblit encore gérard pia qui se
trouvent en france dit qu'il veut il
aime beaucoup faire du ski alpin mais
qu'il aimerait bientôt essayer la
raquette de la fameuse raquette dans la
neige l'hiver
moi j'en fais parce que je suis
maintenant outillés depuis deux ans pour
le faire j'ai tout ce qu'il faut les
bottes les raquettes bien sûr et vous
savez ce qu'il existe maintenant à
nouveau un nouvel outil j'allais dire
mais non à nouveau en fait de nouveaux
skis qui sont à la fois des raquettes et
des skis et ski de fond et des raquettes
wyss porte un nom un peu étrange mais au
sein du mélange donc entre eux du ski de
fond et de la récurrence qui sait bien
c'est tout à fait ça à cette belle
marque dassler lasky d'arras qui écoute
et on va en parler beaucoup de ce qui
aujourd'hui à l'émission parce que c'est
un des deux grands sports favoris les
canadiens l'autre état le hockey au bout
ça aussi on veut accabler pour moment je
voudrais vous êtes serris vers les
pentes de ski au canada on a la
réputation d'avoir beaucoup de neige
mais c'est pas toujours le cas avec le
réchauffement climatique on a connu des
hivers il ya eu des ratés
bien sûr nous avons la technologie pour
faire face à tout ce qui ce que ce que
mère nature nous offre nous avons des
canons à neige mais canons à neige si
vous voulez et il ya une autre vie
récemment café maryse jobin notre
collègue de la salle francophone du
département français où deux membres de
la section française de radio-canada et
elle a fait une entrevue avec un homme
qui s'appelle yves juneau pdg de
l'association des stations de ski du
québec pour nous parler du rôle
primordial que jouent ces canons à neige
au québec qu'elle vit de façon
particulièrement de la province ou un
incontournable la vélostation comme
roman que plus de 2000 canons à neige
pour façonner dans les effectifs
dans un talon aiguille la difficulté ces
dames alla le réchauffement des
températures parce que pour fabriquer de
la neige
on a quand même besoin d'avoir une
température sous le point de congélation
idéalement on parle de moins sept degrés
et comme je viens d'en après le jeu avec
un noël à plus vite vous pouvez pas
fabriquer neige à ce moment là alors ça
c'est dommageable
la roma cette année on est dans un
contexte plus favorable avec l'arrivée
des tables on a quand même eu un mois de
novembre plutôt tôt où il s'est un petit
peu de neige mais la maman les
températures froides pendant les nuits
nous permettent de faire fonctionner les
canons et berna tueur nous garde avec un
cadeau de neige naturelle et puis ça je
voudrais que c'est le maire outil de
promotion qu'on peut avoir pour effet
les tables alors là comment ça se passe
sur les collines les montagnes ici pas
loin de nous avons transmet en ce moment
un commentaire de françoise de perdus en
france
quel beau nom de famille n'est ce pas et
elle répond à notre question tam-tam
quel est votre sport favori je vous
demande anne marie de nous lire cette
réponse genre madame depardieu nous dit
ici dans le sud de la france nous
n'avons pas beaucoup de neige mais si
vous faites un saut vers les montagnes
en moins de deux heures on est au
paradis des skieurs
et elle ajoute personnellement je me
défends assez bien sur les pistes mais
je prends de l'âge et du poids me dit
mon mari et je n'ose plus m'offrir en
spectacle en fait ce n'est perdu
il ajoute je préfère le petit vin blanc
après la descente de ski
il m'arrive parfois de rêver être une
championne de ski aux olympiques
j'avais ce rêve tout petit et maintenant
que je suis toute grosse comme le titre
je laisse à mes deux jeunes enfants
porter ce rêve pour moi accepter ma
merci fanta ces commentaires on va en
afrique retour en afrique au togo
kouassi woods anne-marie vous lisez
cette réponse il dit ici au togo et plus
précisément en afrique de l'ouest il ne
neige pas mais mon sport d'hiver favori
et le saut à skis parce que descendre
d'une pente sur une rampe pour décoller
donc le tremplin en essayant d'aller
aussi loin que possible et très
fascinant rien qu en le décrivant je le
vis déjà un amateur de sensations et il
a beaucoup d'imagination en plus il
arrive à imaginer ses sensations est ce
que vous imaginez le scénario suivant
est en train de faire du ski alpin vous
descendez la montagne il ya vous êtes
pratiquement seul sur la montagne et
tout d'un coup c'est le vide dessous vos
skis la montagne se défait c'est
l'avalanche
c'est ce qu'il s'est produit c'est la
vidéo virale cette semaine l'événement
s'est produit la semaine dernière dans
les montagnes de la colombie britannique
un jeune homme dans la vingtaine il a
tout filmé avec son casque et c'est sur
ces notes penser à bien sûr tout est
super c'est une aide points c'est à ceux
là page de tam-tam canada vous pouvez
revoir cette vidéo pour ceux qui n'ont
pas encore vu la voici la voilà
oh
[Musique]
où
alors voilà c'est sur radio canada
international la page de tam-tam canada
s'ils voulaient revoir ces images et
anne-marie oui vous connaissez le truc
pourquoi il a survécu où il a survécu
c'est quand même étonnant parce qu'il
était dans un nouvel habit gonflables au
niveau de la tête il avait deux bus
leurs anges et lorsqu'il a vu ce qui se
passait là l'appareil c'est à gonfler en
5 secondes là c'est instantané ça gonfle
et ça vous permet de rester au dessus de
la neige il a fait mille a culbuté bien
sûr et ça c'est une nouvelle technologie
qui existe depuis quelques années en
fait il ya plusieurs modèles
présentement sur le marché
d'ailleurs quel hasard cette semaine
j'ai fait une entrevue
enfin une autre vie un dossier sur les
nouvelles technologies dans le domaine
des avalanches
j'ai une suite dans les idées du manager
de l'idée dans la suite de ses patrons
mais voici la suite avec cette vidéo sur
un téléviseur
on pourrait s qu'on pourra les voir ce
qui s'appelle sur youtube x avalanche
extraits de reportages et ce moment
changements au programme donc ça c'est
ce que c'est ce que je fais c'est très
court une minute sur 6 mais voici
l'essentiel
la motoneige de neige et le ski de
randonnée sont les deux activités les
plus risquées en montagne ils
représentent respectivement 40% et 29 %
de tous les décès enregistrés depuis
l'hiver 2007 henry a beaucoup de banques
aba qui l'ont construite en forme et
pour sensibiliser des habitués des
sports de montagne découvre par exemple
de deux jours existe notamment
typiquement en janvier et février
l'instructeur cannes bélanger de
l'entreprise adventures puis sixty five
d'abord il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
vont arriver ça devient je vais pas
d'effet à la mode mais disons que c'est
certain que c'est quelque chose qui
attire beaucoup des gens pour plusieurs
raisons sur l' aventure crois pas ça si
une seule estimée motoneige une seule la
neige poudreuse et on écran part de dire
au canada en fait on est le leader dans
tous les pays d'europe équilibre des
cours d'avalanche dans la profonde âge
déjà qui ont pris fait que ce genre de
cours en éducation
mais on a toujours du chemin à faire le
tour du monde qui sont souvent ceux du
monde qui se fait peut-être une 1/2 ans
et paco mi-temps qui s'intéressent à la
hanche et puis là ils disent à bergerac
où certains je suis vaut mieux comme par
le court au départ de l'expérience
davanture bande d'arrêt
alors voilà ça c'est si vous voulez voir
la suite bien sûr c'est sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine sous la
rubrique fouiller dans nos archives
on est là pour ça vous fouillez on a
fait des choses un passé qu'ils ont
encore d'un intérêt d'actualité si vous
voulez vous les faire vivre
justement en fouillant les archives
cette semaine ggg j'ai trouvé ça et
ensuite j'ai été j'ai eu et j'ai eu ça
m'a fait beaucoup de peine parce que
j'ai dit mon jeu sapad allure yakup
d'année en fin 2014 on a fait une
entrevue avec un jeune homme dans la
boue by trentaine qui s'appelait jean
philippe auclair spécialiste de ce qu'on
appelle le ski moule donc le ski de
montagne une activité extrêmement
populaire plutôt que le ski alpin ou le
le ski de un peu l'un l'a donc mieux
d'évaluer ce qui a changé c'est le
stress qu'il faut renverser
je suis pas un expert j'en ai fait
qu'une fois dans ma vie du ski de fond
mais il a eu aussi le ski mont 16h vous
quittez quand l'autre main les uns droit
de
on où il ya des montées vous mentez vous
même vous aller dans des endroits un peu
sauvage et vous allez vous prenez des
risques fait du ski hors piste mais
voilà il appelle seul ce qui me pousse à
completel tous les risques sont permis
en fait lui il est décédé et jean
philippe est décédé en 2014 dont
quelques mois après nous avons accordé
cette entrevue
je vous suggère de l'écouter sur son
plaisir de faire du ski l'hiver et en
sachant ce qui lui est arrivé c'est très
cesser cette crise et la vie et des
dangers dans les sports parfois on
écoute comme les rocheuses comme les
alpes c'est plus grands plus lourds mais
[Musique]
la presse européenne ce qui je déménage
et en apprendre un peu se passer de ce
côté-là priés de passer plus de temps
possible avec des gens qui ont
l'expérience dans le domaine de
l'alpinisme à chamonix
c'est ça qui m'intéresse le plus parce
que c'est celle là plus que j'en connais
le moins
un orage jean philippe auclair 1977 2014
il est décédée dans une avalanche avec
un de ses copains au chili on a retrouvé
son corps au sujet des statistiques vos
chances de survie sont quand même assez
élevé si vous deviez tomber dans une
avalanche
oui au canada entre une et dix huit
minutes
si on arrive à vous repêché à vous
trouver ou chances de survie serait de
90 % 91% voix
c'est un matin si c'est entre la 30 dont
35 minutes et 120e minute quelles sont
vos chances de survie 71% non une chance
sur cinq dont 20 pour ça les minutes
quand parce qu'évidemment vous le secret
de ceux qui ont survécu souvent c'est de
se mettre en boule
oui et de créer une bulle d'air autour
d'eux s'ils le peuvent bien sûr si le
poids de la neige les enfants avec le
nouvel équipement dont vous avez parlé
plutôt les chances devrait être voilà
beaucoup plus grand mais de s'en sortir
on dit qu'il ya deux fois plus de gens
qui sont qui font du ski dans l'eau dans
nos montagnes où il ya des risques mais
que les statistiques n'ont pas augmenté
en fait le nombre de personnes qui
décèdent dans les avalanches au canada a
chuté de moitié
si on compare la situation il ya trente
ans alors c'est quand même le lire on
peut faire des progrès au niveau de
l'équipement mais aussi de la sécurité
je sais qu'on doit parler de hockey en
simple avant avant de parler de hockey
stéphane vous avez posé la question quel
est votre sport d'hiver préférée c'est
celle qu'elle le vôtre en fait je suis
incapable de faire de ski de fond pas de
ski de ski alpin ou de saison de ski
alpin j'en ai jamais fait de ski de fond
rouge en effet une fois que j'ai fait
par un cheval il a fallu hier
dîner du cheval il enquêtait uniquement
ce qui j'ai avancé et je n'y ai piqué ni
il s'est retourné pour bruay et j'ai eu
le temps de partager les chevals sur une
piste de ski de force basque et baba
même temps de piste juste fils j'étais
j'ai des amis au vermont aux états unis
une charmante dame qui m'a dit va faire
de ski façon près en egypte est bon le
papa je suis incapable de patiner
là je passe une heure je sais quel est
votre sport d'hiver préféré ma raquette
pendant le ping pong vous avez présenté
la question devant une table de ping
pong à payer les années que j'en ai pas
joué un du ping pong l'intérieur je rêve
d'avoir ma propre table de ping pong
mais on viendra l'action et lors des
sports d'hiver les sports d'été préférée
des canadiens dans quelques mois cet
accord est promis au niveau du hockey
vous allez sur la page web de tam-tam
canada vous allez retrouver deux
reportages sur la fièvre du hockey qui
nous gagne tous les mois d'avril et mois
de mai chaque année indépendamment du
fait que les canadiens ou non font
partie des éliminatoires l'équipe des
canadiennes montréal la plus fabriquée
pour monde mais ce sont les finales je
pense que c'est pour ça les gens sont
autant d'intérêt à ce moment aussi un le
regard expert d'un scientifique sur la
vitesse de frappe des hockeyeurs parce
que les hockeyeurs frappe ce qu'on
appelle une rondelle dans le langage de
tous les jours
la pac et c'est ça il ya et apparemment
il ya toute une science derrière
comment heurté c'est mieux qu'au coco
galles
c'est une technique et on parle aussi
dans cette entrevue de raymond des
marteaux sur la plage de tam-tam canada
du fait que les pourquoi les gardiens
ont augmenté 1 je pense qu'ils ont parlé
de 30 % d'augmentation en termes de
poids ces dégâts beaucoup plus lourd
pourquoi la science encore une vraie
espace puis on est en train de couvrir
c'est pas l'équipement qui est imposante
c'est pas l'équipe si l'homme en dessous
c'est le monde a en tout cas c'est des
beaux sujets de conversation ce qu'ils
veulent
réchauffer leur hiver il ne reste à
discuter ensemble
j'aimerais que les eaux vous nous aidiez
jeu parce que vous êtes un amateur de
bonne nourriture en fait je pense que
parmi les trois ici autres dates à ce
problème à celui qui cuisine mieux ou
sans accord c'est votre et par mois je
seulement les choses qui vont au
barbecue ah bon habituellement c'est un
homme celle expertise l'homme de cro
magnon ce que vous mangez beaucoup de
viande
en fait on essaie de manger moins de
viande mais c'est vrai que votre
expertise jeu fois par semaine en fait
parfois chaque deux semaines
enfin bon bah oui que vous faites ça des
hivers comme été oui oui je peux vous
envoyer des photos si vous voulez des
mois un train de faire à -40 en fait
l'année passée pour moi m'a fait c'est
le 7 février
vous voulez la semaine prochaine vous
mettez ça sur le web et on le montre la
photo ap photo un qui se fait c'est
moins 40 puis on a fait un barbecue à
l'extérieur safran se fera une bonne
chose ça on va croquer sur la semaine
prochaine parce que la semaine prochaine
question va porter sur la bonne bouffe
et la malbouffe à les deux parce que je
pense que votre menu de barbecues sont
pas les deux en même temps et plus sans
faire peur c'est bien j'espère quel
genre de questions qu'on peut leur poser
rappelez vous ils habitent non seulement
au canada mais habite aussi à l'étranger
oui aux etats unis la manche fait existe
partout il a beau aussi d'ailleurs
entre la malbouffe et la bonne bouffe ou
si tu jouais ici
oui on pourra aller dans un restaurant
filmé et c'est parce que j'ai entendu
dernièrement
savez-vous quelle part du budget des
américains passent en restauration
n'importe quel restauration rapide ou au
delà un tiers non plus que ça au canada
c'est à peu près un tiers mais on craint
que ça n'augmente au cours des
prochaines années alors on a beau sortir
des livres de recettes
avoir des émissions de cuisine les gens
de cuisine de moins en moins et vont de
plus en plus haut restant mais c'est la
faute des gardiens de but est d'être
écoutés à marivan merci beaucoup d'être
venu cette semaine avant de se quitter
vous nous rappeler ce qui assure espèces
autochtones à radio canada cette semaine
dont vous êtes une des artistes
principal oui en fait je vais vous
parler du sujet que j'ai réalisé cette
semaine nous allons parler du microbiome
des inuit
justement on s'intéresse à ce que les
inuit mange et comment ça se voit dans
leur microbes intestinaux
comment l'eure l'eure l'eure l'eure
l'eure faune intestinale est différente
ou ressemblante à ce que mangent les
occidentaux en général vous le voulez
nous envoyer un hyperlien d'un pourquoi
pas mettre ça sur la page autant pour la
semaine prochaine absolument d'accord je
fais ça s'il y avait une troisième
personne autour de la table je suis sûr
qu'on pourrait lui demander un devoir
également on va leur demander à ceux qui
nous écoutent ou qui nous regarde
présentement la caméra fait vos devoirs
répondez à notre prochaine question tu
entames entre malbouffe et bonne bouffe
où vous situez-vous ici stéphane parent
à la semaine prochaine